Nick Carter and his wife Lauren revealed  their stunning maternity pics the couple  shared the beautiful photos shot by Lori  Dorman exclusively with et Lauren is  showing off her bump covered in gorgeous  lace while husband Nick lovingly gazes  at her Nick told us they could barely  look at one another while tearing up  during the emotional shoot whoa I hate  getting emotional but seeing her like  that triggered this influx of emotions  that really made me realize what's  happening in our life it's crazy how  much more in love you can become when  you start this phase of your life it has  been a complicated pregnancy for the  couple but now that both mom and son are  healthy the duo can't wait to meet their  first child the parents their pregnancy  during Nick's stint on Dancing with the  Stars last year so right now one is 16  weeks pregnant it still seems  unbelievable